ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
Birthday ค่ะก็นักเรียนก็กลับมาเจอกับ
เรา 2 คนอีกแล้วนะคะไทยหันในบีกินเนอร์
คลาสนะคะครูฟ้าแล้วก็ครูหญิงค่ะใส่แล้ว
เนาะครูฟ้าขาวันไหนวันอะไรคะ
วันนี้อยู่วันพุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธนะคะวัน
พุธที่เท่าไหร่คะฟ้าวันพุธที่ 16
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพตต
2556  5  5  8 ปีคศอะไรคะเมื่อปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้
วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
15 ดีเดือนเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตตปีพตต
2565 ปี 6
ต.ค.ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่
คะ
วันที่ 17 ค่ะดีเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์อุ้ยดี
พ.ต.ต.
อีคอทส์
2565 เบคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะก่อนแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
แล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
11:05 ค่ะ
11:05 น
08:05 นก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
รางวัลนี้ล่ะแล้วไปอเมริกากี่โมงคะผู้
หญิงครีมก็จะเป็นเวลา
11:00 นนะคะ 11:00 น 5  5 นาที
ของครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นเวลากลางคืนครูฟ้า
กลางวันเหมือนที่ภูฟ้าบอกนะคะเราตรงข้าม
กันหมอเขาครูฟ้ากลางวันครูหญิงกลางคืน
กรุงข้ามกันไอแล้วค่ะก็เป็นไงคะผู้หญิง
ตอนนี้คุณหญิงสบายสบายดีค่ะสมัยครูหญิง
แม่กำลังจะนอนเนาะแต่พรูฟ้าเนี่ยว่าตอน
นี้เป็นเวลา 11:00 นใช่ไหม 11 โมงแล้ว
อันนี้ประมาณนะคะ 11 โมงเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ก็อาจจะหิวใช่ไหมคะแบบคิ้วปอก
ของเนี่ยท้องอยู่ที่นี่นะคะอาจจะๆๆคิวอาจ
จะอยากกินอาหาร
screw ฟ้าก็ต้องไปทำอาหาร
ใช่ค่ะกูฟ้าหิวเห้ยทำอาหาร
ทำอะไรครูฟ้าทำอาหารเนี่ยครูฟ้าพี่เล็กทำ
อาหาร
ที่ไหนคะ
ทำอาหารที่ห้องครัวค่ะนี่สมัยดูเป็นห้อง
ครัวไหมคะ
ในฮะนี่หัดนี่เนาะห้องครัว
ทองครัว
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้าน
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีห้องครัวสมัยมีห้อง
ครัว
ต้องหัดสวดนายวีนก็เลยนี่ก็มีห้องครัวแน่
ผู้หญิงก็มีครอบครัวเหรอดีค่ะครูหญิง
เนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่บ้านใช่ไหมครูหญิงเนี่ย
อยู่
Apartment  Condominium นะคะอันนี้ของ
ผู้หญิงสะบัดก็มีห้องมีรั้ว
Dictionary ค่ะนักเรียนมีห้องครัวไหมคะ
ขาตายแล้วแต่ห้องครัวสมัยห้องครัวบ้านผู้
หญิงกับห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมันอาจจะ
ไม้นี่เหมือนกันหรือว่าโทรหาจากตรงข้าม
กันก็ได้ใช่ไหมวันนี้นะคะผู้หญิงกับครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยก็จะมาบอกนักเรียนว่าที่บ้านครู
อุ๋ยกะที่ Condominium ครูหญิง
Apartment  Condominium เลยนะคะแล้วก็
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยในห้องครัวสมัยห้อง
ครัวมีเนาะของเราเนี่ยมีอะไรบ้าง
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าห้องครัวมีอะไรบ้างเราจะวาดรูปเนาะ
เดี๋ยวขอ Share  screen แป๊บนึงนะคะนัก
เรียน
ควีนเลยอ่ะมีจุดปักโลโก้นาหารผู้หญิงแฮช
สร้อย vnsharing
ครูหญิงกำลัง Share  screen อ่ะมาแล้วใช่
ไหมคะครูฟ้า
fatigue เกอร์รี่มาแล้วป๋า
ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงแบ่งครึ่ง
โอ้
เรากำลังจะ
นี่ค่ะ
อันนี้นะคะของครูหญิงหาผู้หญิง
ห้องครัวบ้านครูหญิงสีน้ำเงิน
กลัวผู้หญิงสีน้ำเงินของครัวบ้านครูฟ้าสี
แดงสีแดง
เหมือนคุณใช้อะไรเขียนแล้วนะคะอ่ะ
คุณครูค้าที่บ่อฟ้าเนี่ยห้องครัวบ้านครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยมีอะไรคะ
ห้องครัวบ้านกูขามนี้
ตู้เย็นค่ะ
มีตู้เย็น
โอ้โหตู้เย็นใช่ไหมที่เวลาเปิดก็มีโค้กมี
แป๊บซี่มีหมูมีไก่ตู้เย็น
ทำ
อะไรอ่ะ
นั่ง 11 ตู้เย็นตู้เย็น
ทุเรียนไม่แน่ใจก็ดีค่ะผู้หญิงมีรูปให้ดู
ตู้เย็น
ตู้เย็นแล้วอ่ะห้องครัวที่บ้านผู้หญิงมี
อะไรคะพ่อมึงครัวบ้างครูหญิงเนี่ยอะไรขอ
ดูรูปด้วยนะคะมีอันนี้ค่ะครูฟ้าอ่ะอา
ลีฮะ
แค่
ผู้ฟ้ารู้ไหมคะอะไหล่
เต่าแก่ค่ะ
ไม่ใช่เหรออันนี้บ่าวโอโออ้าห้องครัวบ้าง
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีเตาอบนี่ๆนักเรียนดูรูป
ประกอบด้วยนะคะเพื่อผู้หญิงว่าแล้วนัก
เรียนไม่เข้าใจเนาะเตาอบใช้เวลานักเรียน
คิดทำพิซซ่าก็เอา pizza ใส่เข้าไปที่ดีจะ
ได้เตาอบโอ่งเอาตัวไปผู้หญิงมีเตาอบค่ะ
แล้วห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามีอะไรอีกคะห้อง
ครัวบ้างฟ้ามีปุ๋ย
อันนี้มือไปโดนหรอคะไม่มีอะไรไหมไม่มี
อะไรเลย
หือ
อะไรห้ามัน
เต้าแก๊สเหรอ
ใช่ฮะผู้หญิงเตาแก๊สค่ะ
เวลาทำอาหารเตาแก๊ส
ก็แค่จะ
ห้องครัวบ้านครูหญิงนะคะก็มีเตาเหมือนครู
ฟ้านะแต่ไม่ใช่เตาแก๊สห้องครัวไปอีกแบบ
นี้
แล้วก็มี
ที่นี่
แม่งถ้าเป็นเตาทำอาหารเหมือนกันแต่ไม่ใช่
เตาแก๊สเนอะเราเรียกเตาไฟฟ้า
เตาไฟฟ้า
หือนี้ค่ะให้นักเรียนดูรูปด้วยนะคะ
เห็ดไว้อ่ะเนาะเตาไฟฟ้า
เตาไฟไหม้
เราเหมือนกันแต่ไม่ใช่เตาแก๊สนะค่ะแล้ว
ห้องครัวบ้านคุณฟ้ามีอะไรอีกคะ
ห้องครัวว่างทุกคราวนี้
มีอะไร
ละอ่ะซิงค์ล้างจานค่ะอ๋ออออ๋อ
เว็บเอ่อทำเสร็จแล้วก็มีน้ำน็อตซิงค์ล้าง
จานน้ำมีน้ำซิงค์ล้างจานค่ะ 4
น่าจะกินไหมนะจะได้นะ
ถ้าน้องก็ห้องครัวบ้านครูหญิงก็มีซิ้งค์
ล้างจานเหมือนกันเหมือนครูบาเนี่ยซิงค์
ล้างจานอากาศ
ผู้หญิงก็มีหรอคะนี่ค่ะแต่ว่าของครูหญิง
เนี่ยไม่เอาครูฟ้ามีแล้วไงห้องครัวบ้าน
ครูหญิงเนี่ยมีเตาไฟฟ้าใช่ไหมเวลาทำอาหาร
เนี่ยบางครั้งเนี่ยมันก็มีควันว่าผิดน่ะ
ค่ะมีควันมีควันมีควันหรือใช่ไหมมีควัน
อ่ะกับกู Apartment เนี่ยไม่โอเคใช่ไหม
ข้างบนเตาเนี่ยก็จะมี
อันนี้ค่ะ
ไม่รู้นักเรียนจะเข้าใจหรือเปล่านะคะแล้ว
ก็ที่นี้มีสวิตซ์ใช่ไหมสวิตซ์เปิดขอราคา
เปิดแล้วก็จะมีพัดลม
[เพลง]
คืออะไรภาษาไทยเราบอกว่าเครื่องดูดควัน
เวลาทีเวลาที่เราทำอาหาร
ใช่ไหมคะในห้องครัวเราเรียกว่าเครื่องดูด
ควัน
นักเรียนอาจจะเคยเห็นเป็นหน้าตัวนี้แล้ว
กันเข้าใจง่าย
ตรงนี้เนาะเป็นเครื่องดูดควันนะคะเวลาที่
เราทำอาหารแล้วมันมีควันเยอะๆก็จะมันจะ
ดูดควันค่ะ
แล้วห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามีอะไรอีกคะ
ห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามีอันนี้ค่ะ
มีอะไร
ถูก
เวลาดูแลที่สี่เหลี่ยมเนาะอ่ะอ้าวกูฟ้า
เปลี่ยนใจแล้ว
มันไม่เหลี่ยม
เมื่อไหร่คะครูฟ้า
ไม่ได้เข้าใจแล้วคืออะไรขอคุยรู้ค่ะอะไร
อะไรเข้ากู้หญิง
ไมโครเวฟค่ะถูกต้อง
ไม่เคยหรือเปล่า
ครูบ้านครูฟ้ามีไมโครเวฟ
ไมโครเวฟ nana เรียนใหม่โกรธมีและผู้หญิง
ห้องครัวบ้านผู้หญิงไม่มีไม่มีไมโครเวฟ
แต่ห้องครัวบ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยมีอันนี้ค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
อะไรเอ่ยเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงว่านอย่างนี้แล้ว
กันเนาะ
ก็เดี่ยวให้นักเรียนดูรูปเอานะคะเราเรียก
ว่ามีเครื่องล้างจาน
สวัสดิ์หลานจานเวลาที่เรากินข้าวแล้วก็
เอาใส่คะเอาใส่ในนี้แล้วซึ่งกฏ
เราก็รออ่ะมันก็จะล้างจานห้องครัวบ้านครู
หญิงเนี่ยมีเครื่องล้างจานค่ะครูฟารอน
โอ้โหนี่หากผู้หญิงอ่ะห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้า
มีอะไรอีกคะ
ห้องครัวบ้างกูพาเมียอันนี้
อะไรคะ
ทำนาย
เอเอนักเรียนเดี๋ยวเข้าใจไม่น่า
อะไรอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงดูก็ไม่เข้าใจค่ะอ่ะ
มีอะไรครูฟ้า
นี่ไง
มันคืออะไรคะครูฟ้าจะวาดตรงนี้ก่อนนะได้ๆ
จะ
ให้นักเรียนดู
แม่นักเรียน
เครื่องปิ้งขนมปัง
โอ้โห
ฟ้าวาดใหญ่ก็เลยงงขอท้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามี
เครื่องปิ้งขนมปัง
เรื่องปิ้งขนมปังค่ะมีหล่ะโอโห้
เป็นขนมกลาง
อาทิตย์ขึ้นมาคือขนมปังใช่ไหมคะขนมปังแบบ
นี้เลยโตโห
ห้องอยู่บ้าน
จะใส่ท้องโทรบ้านแค่นี้นะไม่มีเครื่อง
ปิ้งขนมปังค่ะครูฟ้าแต่ห้องครัวบ้านผู้
หญิงมีอันนี้
อะไรคะผู้หญิง
[เพลง]
เครื่องชงกาแฟ
สมัยกาแฟก็คือเอสเพรสโซ่อเมริกาโน่ลาเต้
ใช่ไหมคะเป็นเครื่องชงกาแฟอ่าเดี๋ยววิ่ง
ให้นักเรียนดูรูปด้วยนะคะนี่ค่ะห้องครัว
บ้านครูอุ๋ยเนี่ยมีเพื่งชงกาแฟ
บ้านครูฟ้ามีไหม
ไม่มีค่ะเครื่องทำกับข้าวมีอะไรดีคะตั้ง
ปลุกฟ้าเนี่ย
บ้านฟ้ามีว่านี้เขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
ไม่ถนัดเลยเดี๋ยวนะคะอ่ะรอแป๊บนึงให้ครู
ฟ้าวาดรูปก่อนนะคะ
เรียนเข้าใจไหม 4 ก็หา
ไม่เรียนรู้ไหมเอาคืออะไร
อ๋อ
กระติกน้ำร้อนใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงเวลา
ที่ร้อนอยากดึกน้ำร้อนๆที่บ้านครูฟ้าที่
ห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามีกระติกน้ำร้อนกระติก
น้ำร้อนค่ะถูกต้องแบบนี้เลยอ๋อ
ห้องครัวบ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่มีกระติกน้ำ
ร้อนนะคะครูฟ้าอ้าแต่ว่ามีคล้ายๆกันอัน
นี้อันนี้
มีอะไรมีผู้หญิงวาดรูปก่อน
นายหาผู้หญิง
อะไรเอ่ยใส่กระติกน้ำร้อนนักเรียน
อันนี้ค่ะ
มันคืออะไรนะการ์ตูนน้ำกากน้ำ
แบบนี้แบบนี้เตะกาต้มน้ำใช่ไหมข้างใน
เนี่ยก็ใส่น้ำล่ะคะมีน้ำสมัยเราก็รอน้ำ
เดือด 100 องศาเซลเซียสต่อเป็นกาต้มน้ำ
นิดของตัวบ้านครูหญิงค่ะไหนลองมาดูซิว่า
ข้อครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามีอะไรบ้างคะ
ห้องครัวบ้านครูฟ้ามี 1
รถตู้เย็นค่ะตู้เย็นนะคะ 2 เตาแก๊สค่ะ
3 ซิงค์ล้างจาน
ซิงค์ล้างจาน 4
ไมโครเวฟค่ะ
5 เครื่องปิ้งขนมปัง
ออกกระติกน้ำร้อนร้อนกระติกออกค่ะโอเคของ
ผู้หญิงหรอคะมีอะไรบ้างของผู้หญิงก็จะมี 1
เตาอบเนาะ
2 เตาไฟฟ้านะคะ 3 เครื่องดูดควัน
4 เครื่อง
มีร้านจานผ้าเครื่องล้างจานค่า
เครื่องทำกาแฟน้องดูเครื่องชงกาแฟ
3  6
กาตอมน้ำมาหานี่ก็คือห้องครัวบ้านสุหญิง
แล้วก็
บ้านครูฟ้าน้องแล้วไอ้ห้องครัวบ้านนัก
เรียน Apartment  Condominium  8 อะไรก็
ได้นะคะที่เป็นที่ที่นักเรียนนอนเนี่ยมี
อะไรบ้างก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะตัวนี้
เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ